- I am a actor.
- I'm a Physician, I
practice Emergency Medicine.
- I work at Buzzfeed.
- And I teach high school math.
- There's nowhere we'd rather be right now
than taking this awful, awful test.
(campy upbeat music)
- You take the SATs in high school, right?
See, this is already goin bad.
- I studied for probably an
entire year for this exam.
- I didn't study, like a
lot of the other folks.
- My father got this video
where it taught sense memory.
If you smell an apple, you'll
remember certain phrases
and words and equations,
so I brought my apple today.
- I am a teacher, and I do
value standardized testing,
but I also think that the SAT
advantaged privileged populations,
and so students who don't
have the opportunity
to take extra classes, won't do as well.
Which isn't fair.
- Alright, let's do it.
(sniffs)
- I'm ready.
- Can you show this on the internet?
- Well, now I don't
want to say it out loud,
but that's my general attitude, so.
- You said bleep this.
(laughter)
- I wrote about Hitler,
this can't be good.
- I wrote about rappers, so.
I felt like what I wrote was kinda like
what Kanye would say.
So I'm very confident in what I wrote.
- Alright, question 17 in section two.
In the x-y plane, which I have
no idea what that is anymore,
the line L passes through the origin,
what is an origin?
- Okay, probably a family
symbol, or something like that?
- You guys are on number six?
- Look at that.
- Catch up.
- Bleep me.
- This is important.
- Sentence three: The
harmful effects of smoking
on the vascular system
are increasingly well documented.
That's a fact.
- Whoever wrote these paragraphs,
sounds like a complete
douchbag when they write.
- Yeah, I think it's written in the most
convoluted way possible,
to test your "reading comprehension,"
but in fact, it's just,
it's like bad writing.
- I'm gonna cry.
This is so bad.
(upbeat campy music)
- Okay.
(papers rustling)
(bell dings)
- Alright.
- That's not as bad as I thought.
- Hey hey, I'll take it.
- My math is lower than everything else,
which is horribly embarrassing.
(laughs)
Even though I scored pretty good.
- So in high school, I had
a perfect score in math,
and it's my worst score here.
- Failed at math.
- For me personally, I don't think
it's gonna change anything at this point.
You know I'm not planning
on going back to undergrad,
I think I've done enough
school at this point.
- It was more a test
of who knew the tricks
around the problems, rather than
how smart you actually are.
- I think it's good to have a
standardized test, honestly,
but don't stress too much about it.
- I didn't even do well
enough to get into undergrad,
or whatever, but once you're there,
just work hard there.
Your life is not defined by any one score.
(upbeat campy music)
- This person spelled Kevin wrong.
She/he gets an F in critical reading.